[Music]
Logan what did you do the Charles the
world is not the same as it was
mules
the Ghana I hurt myself today to see if
I still feel I focus on the thing
the only thing that's real fishy they
need this she's like you of time very
much like you the feeling disappear she
needs our help
you are someone come on
someone has come along I am still right
here and you could
Oh
[Music]
would find a way noggin you still have
time
[Music]
so much has happened since I last saw
you
I lost my hammer like yesterday so
that's still pretty fresh and then I
went on a journey of self-discovery
I love you
[Music]
well you have no idea
I Love You God as the death is invaded
as God
oh I miss this and you know you had a
fight with me
did I win
no I want easily doesn't sound right
that's true
as god is dead we'll be reborn in my
image I thought you'd be glad to see me
need a stopper here now to prevent
Ragnarok the end of everything
so I'm putting together a team
like the old days
surprise this would be such fun
hi
he's a fighter
we go
I'm not a queen or a monster
I'm the goddess of death
what were you the god of again
[Music]
we're the same you and I just a couple
of hotheaded fools yes same Hulk like
fire boy like water mama
kind of both like fire butthole like
raging fire so I like smoldering fire
where do we begin here ago these cops
and lawyers wouldn't dare cross any of
you I mean what happened so what are you
proposing
it's simple kill the Batman here's my
card
Bruce this is Harvey Dent Rachel's told
me everything about you I'm gonna
certainly home not
you wants told me we'd be together did
you mean it
Grayson don't make me your only hope
there Alfred right that's right so a
psychotic ex-boyfriends I should be
aware of oh you have no idea good
evening ladies and gentlemen here
tonight's entertainment well hello
beautiful
nervous I've seen now would have to
become to stop men like him the night is
darkest just before the dawn I promise
you the dawn is coming
the city deserves a better class of
criminal I'm gonna give it time
you'll see
either die a hero or you live long
enough to see yourself become the
villain
will you be one in the back picture
little the day Alfred number so the
Lamborghini did much more subtle I come
from Earth a planet about laws my name
is Peter quill there's one other name
you might know me by star-lord who
star-lord man legendary outlaw guys
forget it
[Applause]
[Music]
so here we are the two thugs an assassin
and a maniac but we're not gonna stand
by his evil wipes out the galaxy I guess
we're stuck together partners are you
telling me the fate of 12 billion people
hands of these criminals
[Music]
[Music]
you know what I see losers why it's
giving us a chance
to do what something good
something bad a bit of both
Oh what the hell I don't got that long a
life spin anyway
[Music]
ain't no thing like me set me they call
themselves the guardians of the galaxy
this might not be the best idea
[Music]
I used to want to save the world this
beautiful place
but the closer you get the more you see
the great darkness within
and I learned this the hard way a long
long time ago
what is your mission to stop the war
what war the war to end all wars weapons
far deadlier than you can ever imagine
the welcome to ours
or you are in more danger than you think
cannot stand by while innocent lives are
lost
be careful Diana
who's this woman she's my secretary sir
she's a very good secretary
it is our sacred duty to defend the
world and it's what I'm going to do
[Music]
[Music]
how could a woman possibly fighting this
fight we use our principles although I
am not opposed to engaging in a bitter
fisticuffs should the occasion arise I
believe there's a hero Norris gives us
strength makes us Noble even though
sometimes we have to give up the thing
we want the most grades in declining you
always appear exhausted
I know I'm trying where you been pal you
don't return my calls I've been kind of
busy taking pictures of your friend
spider-man killed my father no matter
what I do do you love me or not no
matter how hard I try I'm spider-man Ted
it's the ones I love who will always be
the ones who pay I let things get in the
way before there was something I thought
I had to do I don't have to do I like
staying in at night theater to the main
event TVs is gonna put Oscorp on the map
away my father never even dreamed
crazy scientist turns himself into some
kind of a
for mechanical arms welded right onto
his body you take spider-man's pictures
where is it sick of me off your loyalty
to spider-man not your best friend
[Music]
to me how do I find him Peter Peck fine
spider-man or I'll peel the flesh off
her bones
there are bigger things happening here
they mean you
[Music]
let's use behind the mask I have seen
gods fly I've seen men build weapons
that I couldn't even imagine I've seen
aliens drop from the sky yeah but I have
never seen anything like this
how much more you hiding
[Music]
yeah hold
[Music]
my son it is your time
you get to decide what kind of thing you
are going to be
don't freeze I never freeze
[Music]
and bow down
I waited my entire life for this the
world's gonna start over burn it all
what happens now determines what happens
to the rest of the world
[Music]
my name is Peter Parker I'm pretty sure
you know the rest I saved the city fell
in love then I saved the city again and
again and again look I'm a comic book
serial I get a Christmas album and it's
so so popsicle but this isn't about me
not anymore
spider-man swings in once the day zip
zap zop in his little mask and answers
to no one I love you morons dad are you
serious I wanna hear it dad
I love you Oh God my name is Miles
Morales I'm the one and only spider-man
at least that's what I thought you'll be
here for supercollider you're gonna love
this
you're like me that's impossible
all right kids listen up this part is
your universe
soggy it's weird it's gross and this
delicious normal fry is my universe so
you want to learn to be spider-man
teacher yes I can time to swing good
double tap to release and twit out again
whip and release your natural flip hey
guys
who are you I'm Gwen Stacy I'm from
another another dimension
how many more spotty people are there
hey fellas this could literally not get
any weirder it can get weird okay we
need to get back to our universes soon
workload is gonna collapse my family
lives in Brooklyn
[Music]
expired if I don't destroy the collider
none of us will have a home to go home
to remember what makes you different
let's go
is what makes you spider-man
officer I love you wait
[Music]
that way that way other way other way
other way do animals talk in this
dimension cuz I don't want to freak him
out there was an idea to bring together
a group of remarkable people to see if
we could become something more so when
they needed us we could fight the
battles that they never could
[Music]
in time you will know what it's like to
lose feel so desperately that you're
right
yet to fail all the stack
read it
run from it Dustin's still alive
[Music]
[Music]
evacuate the city
engage your defenses
and get this manna sheet
[Music]
August is something one considers
imbalance in the universe
but this does put a smile on my face
[Music]
[Music]
the hell are you guys most of the
intelligence community doesn't believe
he says the ones that do call him the
Winter Soldier he's a ghost you'll never
find him
[Music]
I joined shield to protect people
captain to build a better world
sometimes means tearing the old one down
that makes enemies
fast
[Music]
are you ready all it takes is one step
people are gonna die
again if that happened
Captain America needs my help
when do we start we just did
price of freedom time
and it's a price I'm willing to pay
he told me not to trust anyone
this is our damage everything goes
[Music]
looked like you giving me orders now
captain damn right
how do we know the good guys from the
bad guys if they're shooting at you
they're bad
Hey open the pool good why the fancy red
suit mr. pool well that's because it's
christmas day dopinder and i'm after
someone on my naughty list you're
probably thinking this was a superhero
movie but that guy in the suit just
turned that other guy into a kebab
surprise this is a different kind of
superhero story to tell it right we got
to take you back before I squeezed into
red spandex mr. Wilson you've recently
been diagnosed with terminal cancer we
can fight this what if I told you we can
cure you and give you abilities most men
only dream of I'd say that you sound
like an infomercial but not a good one
like Slap Chop more shake weighty if I
never see you again know that I love you
when I'm finished it mutates its cells
will heal anything but you still think
we're making you a superior we're making
you receivers Fame come on you gonna
leave me all alone here with Jose
Canseco whatever they did to me made my
body indestructible but my face no look
at me I know look at it no I don't want
it exactly I didn't ask to be super and
I'm no hero but when you find out your
worst enemy is after your best girl the
time has come to be a superhero cue the
music
we can't allow this Deadpool I don't
have time for your x-men bull Colossus
besides nobody's getting hurt that guy
was up there before we got here I put a
lot of rolls damsel-in-distress ain't
wanna
wait did I leave the stove on you're way
too much dude for me that's why I
brought down
I mean that's why I brought her oh no
finish your tweet go get her tiger
so pity the dude who pressures her into
prom sex
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the worlds will look up and shout save
us
[Music]
[Music]